the eros dead couldn't be that person
even if I wanted to be and I don't want
to be those like nothing you've ever
seen before well trained for armed we
need here
oh you don't know who I am do you
i'm damian darhk-- so you're all
fretting about this city dying I'm here
on behalf of an organization that wants
you to let it die this town started
going to craft one what you put on I
hope you brought badness into all our
lives in the monster you inspired
monsters
I respect order discipline all you
represent is anarchy I've certainly
chosen an unusual hobby mister even when
we're out there we are not out there
together you almost got killed tonight
because you didn't have each other's
back I don't know what's happening now
but it's not in my job description
ready people go with it come on the same
[Music]
you can't be the arrow he died so who
are you you're about to find out hey
youtubers is Charlie happy fourth Friday
new arrow footage so let's start digging
through it ok so everybody let's freak
out and talk about what's going on here
there's a couple things they say like a
little bit of dialogue but mostly
they're teasing where the characters are
at and some of the new characters
themselves like we see damian darhk-- we
see anarchy here mr. terrific and
probably biggest of all Constantine Matt
Ryan is Constantine I love the fact that
he enters stopping his cigarette before
he appears he's gonna be the one to help
resurrect Sarah I think it's gonna be
episode 5 is what they announced it is
that the problem is is that the Lazarus
Pit only works for a certain period of
time since she's been dead longer than
that they need some extra mojo for those
wondering though Matt Ryan could always
come back as Constantine as long as they
want him back but I don't think that the
show is going to be remade anywhere else
so the scene that we open and is clearly
Oliver and Felicity that have been
living together as regular people for a
while like you know ever since the end
of arrow season 3 it just follows up on
the idea that the arrow is dead that
identity so he's going to be becoming
green arrow that's part of getting the
new costume taking that justice league
level mantle even more interesting is
this Star City memorial to Ray Palmer so
there's a there's so much going on in
this picture they think that Ray Palmer
is dead when he's really just teeny-tiny
and - they've already renamed the City
Star City from Starling city that's a
pretty big deal so I'm expecting them to
address the name change in that first
episode no idea when Ray Palmer is gonna
show up though we have no idea obviously
he's going to be in legends of tomorrow
so at some point during arrow season 4
they'll figure out that he just got
shrunk down I'm kind of wondering if
felicity and mr. terrific are the people
to discover him like oh man you're not
dead you're just really really tiny
speaking of which mr. terrific we see
the t's fierce here you can't have mr.
terrific and not have the t's fears but
obviously this is a much younger version
of the character so he'll probably help
make them with felicity like whenever
he's working at Palmer tech I don't know
exactly what his relationship is going
to be in the organization but Felicity
hires him and hopefully he'll help work
on some arrow technology - like some
crime-fighting technology
speaking of which diggle's new helmet
yes it does look a little bit like
Magneto's helmet and no he is not the
Guardian like he's not a comic book
persona he's still gonna be Diggle but
the helmet is more a nod to Guardian
from the comics than it is to anything
else like they're not trying to infringe
on Marvel's copyright IP or anything
like that it's kind of hard to tell here
but there is like a face shield that
goes over it it looks like he can turn
it black so it looks like it's just made
to hide his identity and keep his brains
from getting squished Willa going
apeshit it looks like she flies off the
handle and that's part of the route
percussions of getting resurrected in
the Lazarus Pit they tease that during
season 3 but I guess season 4 when
they're really following up on it a ways
back Stephen Amell was answering
questions about arrow season four and
one of the teases was you know what's
wrong Willa as in maybe he comes back to
Star City because willow starts going
crazy
here's Felicity unveiling the new suit
as you can see like the foundry set
looks like it's pretty clean like they
haven't been using it in a while like I
said this is an image of the new arrow
cave and it sounds like they might be
building it beneath Palmer tech like it
might be directly beneath their business
it's kind of like in the Christopher
Nolan Batman films where they had the
the special research Sciences Division
inside the Wayne building this dialogue
about Diggle and Oliver makes it sound
like they're still gonna be butting
heads at the beginning of the season
remember Diggle hates the [ __ ] out of
Oliver I don't think they're gonna be at
each other's throats all season long I
think that they'll make up by the end
hopefully by the mid-season finale
nothing brings people together like a
really crazy big villain like damian
darhk-- Quentin Lance here also going
apeshit
he actually restarts the superhero task
force Rutina Wesley from True Blood you
might remember her from Terra's True
Blood she's not playing a comic book
character but she's gonna be part of
that task force storyline this is
actually a picture of her and her full
riot gear but all these vigilantes are
definitely on Quentin's [ __ ] list
Felicity with the machine gun just made
for a pure comedy Jerry Ryan here this
is actually gonna be interesting so 7 of
9 is going to be on arrow I'm so excited
about this she's gonna be playing a mere
candidate she's not a comic book
character but a lot of people have been
asking about the Oliver Queen for mayor
storyline from the comics I don't know
that that's gonna happen we might see
something like that but that kind of
feels like it'd be a rehash of that
season 2 plotline in case you don't
recognize him here this person standing
right here on her right
that is anarchy you can actually see a
better picture of them here Amanda
Waller's back it looks like this might
be from the flashbacks now they said
that they're doing flashbacks they're
plotting them just a little bit
differently but we don't know a lot
about them misson Merlin's going at it
obviously he's still Rachel Ghul but
Nyssa is not a cast regular Merlin is so
I'm not really sure how they're gonna be
using Berlin this season but mostly it
looks like missus just gonna try and
assert the title from him in this final
image of junior born you might remember
him from Teen Wolf he's playing Double
Down from the comics the guy that
Felicity is kicking here so let's
address some of the things that are not
in this trailer so there's one character
that's gonna be associated with Oliver's
past week with the flashbacks like a
past girlfriend that he had a lot of
people think with all this Coast City
Green Lantern teasers that it might be
Carol Ferris now I think that that's
just a lot more likely than than doing a
Green Lantern character but you can hold
that hope otherwise like the big thing
going on in season 4 is the rise of
mysticism so more and more magic but
don't expect a tan or anything like that
like spell magic it's gonna be more
mysticism than outright magic for those
wondering about the flash trailer
because we're within that like that one
month period before the premieres the
flash trailer will probably come
sometime next week so just keep your
eyes peeled for that I'll totally do a
video when it comes be sure to subscribe
to get that I'm still trying to figure
out how to do like the reverse flash
ring giveaway so just keep your eyes
peeled whenever that flash trailer post
I'll start that special giveaway happy
fourth Friday everybody go spend some
money and rewatch this arrow trailer a
couple times I have already done bonus
videos for some of the characters that
they cast on air on the flash I'll put
some extra links in the description so
while we wait for that flash trailer to
drop there have been a couple teasers
you can click here to watch them and you
can click here for some of the voice
teasers from Star Wars Episode seven
they didn't release a new trailer but
there have been some voice clips so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight